لا تعد عمليات المراقبة مجرد لعبة انتظار حيث
يتم تصويرها على التلفزيون وفي
الأفلام ، يمتلك الجواسيس ترسانة من الأدوات
لتتبع الموضوعات كثيرًا
أكثر تعقيدًا من زوج من
المناظير ، على سبيل المثال ،
يمكن لأجهزة الاستماع السرية التقاط الصوت حول
المصطلح  يمكن لأجهزة الكشف عن الليزر الموجهة إلى سيارة متوقفة
أن تشير عندما
يتحرك الهدف ، وبمجرد أن يتحرك يمكن تحديد
موقع الهاتف المحمول والشخص الذي
يحمله بسهولة من
خلال تحديد الموقع الجغرافي ولكنك لست بحاجة
إلى أدوات عالية التقنية لمتابعة علامات التبويب  على شخص ما
في عام 1934 ، قام مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي (FBI) بذلك بالطريقة القديمة
عندما قام بالتنسيق مع جون ديلنجر 20
عميلًا وواحدًا
من أشهر عمليات المراقبة على الإطلاق لاعتقال
سارق البنك سيئ السمعة في أحد دور السينما في شيكاغو
عندما غادر ديلينجر.
لكن العملاء كانوا
أول من أطلقوا النار